JENNY BROWN: How do you
personalize your G Suite Admin
console to suit
your specific needs?
In this quick lab,
we've provided you
with an organization, G Suite
Labs, and a temporary G Suite
domain to work in.
You will make some
basic modifications
to a G Suite Admin
console and then modify
the company profile.
Let's get to it.
So far in the lab, you've
removed and rearranged
some controls from the
Admin console dashboard.
Here we are customizing
the company profile
and adding a support
message that users
will see when they can't sign
into their G Suite account.
We've set a time zone relevant
to our users and select Manual
for new products, so that an
administrator must manually
add new products for
users to have access.
In the lab, you will
also get the opportunity
to bulk add users using a
CSV file and to log in as one
of your newly created
users and experience it
from a user perspective.
In case you're not
familiar, Qwiklabs
is an online
hands-on lab library
available 24 hours a
day, seven days a week,
with more than 150 labs on
every cloud topic from intro
to expert level.
Each lab helps you learn a
new skill in about 30 minutes
using Google Cloud.
When you're ready, use this
link to take the lab we just
went through today.
And when you're ready
to sign up for GCP,
use this link to apply a
$300 credit to your account.
We want to hear from you.
Every week, we'll answer a
question from our viewers.
So let us know what's on your
mind in the comments below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]